joining me now for reaction are two
congressmen from the GOP Wisconsin
congressman Sean Duffy Duffy who's in
Wausau Wisconsin and from the Democratic
Party California Congressman John
Garamendi who is in Sacramento great to
see both of you on a Friday night let's
start with you congressman Duffy
this NRA boycott seems to me to miss the
point of the red flags missed by local
authorities federal authorities and all
the other factors that have clearly come
into play you say there's a whole bunch
of things we should look at first
instead of looking at the NRA let's look
at what failings happen within local law
enforcement look at the feelings of the
FBI look at the failings of the school
that failed to protect these kids from
Nicholas Cruz coming in and shooting
them up but what you've seen happening
across America is you have left-leaning
media companies that are putting
incredible pressure on companies to buy
into the liberal agenda and I think what
they forget these companies forget is
though there might be quartet quartered
in in New York or in California or in
Chicago they try to hawk their wares all
across middle America and we support the
Second Amendment and we've been a silent
majority we were silent all the way up
until the Trump election when we came
out in mass force and elected a new
president and I think though we might
not sign petitions online to boycott we
might not come to rallies you're gonna
see Americans who are offended by what
these companies are doing stand up and
go you know what if I have a choice to
spend my dollar with a pro Constitution
company or one who stepped away from the
NRA I'm gonna spend my money with
companies that support my values and I
think you're gonna see that affect the
bottom line of companies all across
America which i think would be a good
thing congressman Garrett Monday the the
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo is trying
to lure Delta to New York say come to
New York will will treat you well but
you know New York is a nightmare still
for businesses even though they've tried
to bring more businesses back what is
your reaction to this concern about the
from the NRA members and just regular
Americans to say like this is all taking
it a bit too far that the NRA is that is
killing kids come on well the reality is
that boycotts for political and economic
reasons are as old as this nation if you
remember the first Tea Party
I mean the Boston Tea Party that was a
boycott it goes on and on in this nation
where people express their political or
economic views by not involving
themselves with one company or another
for these companies I think the words of
the president of Delta airline probably
is what we ought to look at and that is
that Delta if I heard him correctly
basically he said that that company and
that and he does not want to be involved
in a political debate over issues that
are not directly related to that company
now with regard to the Georgia
Legislature and I suppose the governor
repealing that sales tax exemption I
been down this road before where here in
California there was a huge fight
between the Bay Area airports and Los
Angeles over who could have the the
lowest or the least or no sales tax on
jet fuel so that the fuel would be so
that the planes would go to that
particular Airport so I think Delta will
simply load his planes the fuel
someplace else where they get it I get
it but the problem here is the the
members of the NRA had nothing to do
with this shooting they they're not
responsible for this and truth be told I
think they only had like 13 people get
this Delta you know break on their
airfare it's not that many people but
it's it's a message and it's the same
message that middle America has gotten
from the elites for years that you're
draggers you're obsessed with guns
you're just you're a boy you're a bunch
of idiots that's what that's how they
feel because congressman Duffy I know
you and I have discussed this before and
we use it yeah
I represent a very very large
agricultural district and I will tell
you that there is nobody that I'm aware
of in the California Democratic
delegation that would even begin to
describe my area and the people that I
represent in the way you just did
they're hard-working they have their
views some are conservative summer
but all of them really believe that this
is America and they have and I want Sean
Duffy to get on this
if we're gonna judge people based on an
organization's blood spilled well I hope
Planned Parenthood Israel is is gonna
lose all of its partnerships or
affiliations given the fact that we have
about 57 million babies who never got to
see the light of day there's a lot of
medical waste that includes blood all
over this country it's so to vilify the
NRA when we have three hundred twenty
five thousand babies murdered in an
abortion clinic Planned Parenthood every
year give me a break
go ahead Sean Laura so you hear the
left-wing media talk about saving kids
lives you hear these kids talking about
saving kids lives if you want to save
kids lives I'd look to the Democrat
Party and the Planned Parenthood in the
left-wing media and Planned Parenthood
killed 300 of the most defenseless
voiceless little babies last year alone
if you want to save lives take money
away from from Planned Parenthood and
start attacking ready fascism no
destroying the most yeah three hundred
thousand right the most defenseless
voices among us and then you want to say
you want to go after guns which is a
constitutional right this is the
greatest hypocrisy that's ever existed
on the face of the earth they're not
trying to save lives they're trying to
eat listen do you want this is really
about Laura liberals want us to rely on
government whether it's our housing our
health care our our protection with the
Second Amendment
they want all reliance on government and
this is just one other step in a long
line of things that take away individual
rights and point us to the government to
be responsible for everything so we live
in a great big nanny state from cradle
to grave they care for everything that
we'll ever need in their lives and we
believe as Republicans in individual
responsibility and liberty militarism I
want to defend my family in my home with
my guns if someone comes calling I don't
want to rely on on law enforcement and
liberals say no no government everybody
I will take care of you well I'm Gary
Monday go ahead that's right well I'm
just saying those are those are really
good talking points but what we're
talking about here is really the safety
in our communities and there is an
appropriate and a very good debate going
on in America about what role guns have
in our society and how we could best
detectors
you hear about little kids which I
understand they take away money from
Planned Parenthood do you care about
children well if you care about the poor
Planned Parenthood and your party
support for a Parenthood don't you can't
have it both ways you can't say you're
not going right from law-abiding
citizens and support the killer so
stealing from the NRA to Planned
Parenthood in some segue that I missed
let's get but let me tell you why we
said I mean I thought it was pretty
clear but we're doing it again if you're
confused we're talking about the blood
of children innocent children who are
gunned down on that school and we're
talking about the blood of the most
innocent who are defenseless in the womb
the elderly and in the womb are the most
in the disabled are the most defenseless
in this country and there's a whole
industry that gets millions of dollars
from the federal government who is is is
bought and paid for by the cult of death
that's why you brought it up but go
ahead well Laura if you could just slow
down for a few moments Planned
Parenthood gets no money no money from
the federal government so let's move
beyond a very real problem here in the
United States if you want to talk about
the abortion issue then we can do that
also
but we started this conversation Laura
please don't put words in my mouth and
don't the reality is we have before us
in Washington a very important issue and
that is how are we going to deal with
the gun violence in our nation whether
that is ace whether by suicide
in individual homes or whether it is by
assault weapons as we saw at the schools
this is an important debate and we ought
not move away from that debate on to
other issues which are important also so
let us go back to this issue how are we
going to deal with this okay you a lot
of people want to want to take away gun
ride so they wanted diminish guy I get
that that's a whole debate but we had
the F
and local authorities in the school
itself refusing to act on the obvious
for a lot of different reasons and maybe
it was malfeasance and something maybe
it was a mistake maybe it was an
oversight but those three factors alone
combined together to allow this kid to
go out and get these weapons
it wasn't the NRA he missed the red
flags and the and the FBI we're told the
kids gonna shoot up in school and he you
gotta be kidding me that's a lame
argument congressman Duffy
well let's we did John we've had guns in
our society since our founding and kids
weren't picking up guns and shooting
other kids in school what's happened in
the last twenty thirty forty years
that's caused this phenomenon to take
place if you want to address this
problem you have to look at what's
happening in culture fatherless homes
violence that comes from from Hollywood
in regard to movies and video games we
have a slew of issues that have taken
place that have undermined our families
and our values there's no faith and
morality in our in our community in our
schools and our families any longer you
could look at a whole subset of issues
that are addressing the anger that kids
have right now that cause them to pick
up guns I talked last night cell phones
and a detachment that we have from that
you've been driven for for 20 years that
that'll that'll come up with each new
shooting the bottom line is we have a
crisis in America and it's not guns it's
our culture and the way we reason our
kids all right come on you've raised up
you've raised a very valid point and one
of the things that we need to do is to
use tools that are readily available and
have been available for us for some time
to be used in schools to deal with those
precise issues that you raised that is
the acting out the loneliness that some
people have and the isolation and
bullying that does play take place
coming out of Columbine as well as Sandy
Hook are two very successful programs
that are available in schools it is
interesting to note that in the
President's budget
he removed some fifty million dollars
that was purse
nicely for the purpose of safe schools
that is it that is to make these
programs available to deal with those
cultures that you just described so we
ought to get about begun okay but go
ahead John I know you put it you put in
sixty three billion dollars in this last
budget let's take some of that sixty
three billion dollars we both can agree
that we need school security and you
might have different security for
different communities Mike you might say
I want to arm you know law abiding
teachers who have specific training all
the communities might do something else
but we can agree shore up our schools
let's focus on the things we can agree
on for Nepal right guys